the title is a mouthful using multimedia
and steak all the collaborations to
enhance HIV adherence research and
clinical practice and resource
constrained settings the case of masiva
candy we struggle with the title and and
one of the reasons that it is so long is
because we're trying to do a few things
here while the core of the presentation
will focus on this what's now called
masiva kenny project which is named by
our South African colleagues the broader
issue that we really want to frame this
around really has to do with advances
and we're we're we're all going in terms
of multimedia and technology and how
best to utilize it and to address which
kinds of problems and I'm actually going
to ask well what we're going to what
we're going to do today is my colleague
Ryan will talk about this Center for new
media teaching learning of Columbia and
we're going to talk about the role of in
education in public health around media
and technologies then I want to talk to
you a little bit about the South African
context and why we chose to collaborate
and use multimedia for the adherence
intervention work that we're doing in
South Africa and talk about that
collaborative process which we think is
fundamental to the success of these
kinds of approaches will describe to you
the intervention masiva Kennedy will try
and show you some of it through
demonstration and then i'm going to show
you we've completed the grant and those
of you know about research we've
completed an r34 NIH study which allows
you to develop an intervention and pilot
test it and then tell you about the next
steps and what are the broader
implications of this kind of work so I
want to turn it over to Ryan right now
you just lead over
so hi everyone my name is Ryan Kelsey as
was mentioned before I'm one of the
directors of a fairly unique Center at
Columbia that's called the Center for
new media teaching and learning and
broadly we support advancing educational
practice for all the schools and
departments across Columbia using you
know technology ideally in the most
purposeful of ways and so that means
everything from an a basic course
website support for you know
undergraduates in writing all the way up
to a medical school law school business
school you name it just trying to find
ways to add value using technology to
what's happening educationally as part
of that we invented or co-opted a kind
of approach that fits very well with the
kind of behavioral intervention research
that groups like the HIV Center and I
would suppose Sierra do here at Yale and
that is something we call design
research which is this process by which
we try to really study the audience and
challenges of a particular situation
that's in need of an intervention
identify some kind of hypothesis that we
think will will add value and take that
forward and then design an experienced
pilot tested assess it and have that
feedback into new iterations of what
we're doing one of the area's we've been
the most successful at doing this with
is with a series of projects that we
refer to as the triangle initiative and
that'll be the kind of the focus of the
slice of my center that you'll hear
about today we had a theory a few years
ago that sort of three pillars of what a
university does research education and
then and kind of community impact or
community service could be woven
together using technology and that it
done well would add value to all three
areas all three aims of a research
institution like Columbia or like Yale
and the way we do that is through
projects like massive Akane and so the
way that works is we find a research
partner who's interested in
collaborating
thinking about using media in some way
search out the community that that
researchers interested in working in and
through a participatory design kind of
process that uses that cycle i just
showed build some kind of intervention
in collaboration with the researcher try
it out and then look for ways to fold it
back into the curriculum on the campus
and so the reason for doing that in our
opinion is a lot of especially
professional schools Public Health
social work even journalism on other
schools at least at Columbia are very
interested in building more bridges to
real practice out in the world having
authentic experiences for their students
while they're still studying in
classrooms and we can do that with
technology because the the tools that we
create for particular interventions can
be repurposed and subdivided up and
reused in different kinds of educational
activities and I'll try to make that
more concrete view later in the
presentation as you see some examples
that come out of the of the particular
case of massive akane but I can just say
that they're throughout these
interventions than we've worked on
several of them over the years in
dentistry Social Work Public Health that
there's a way to tease out the sort of
competencies and skills that a lot of
students need to have in various
programs that are doing on campus and
rather than us making one tool to use in
the classroom and another tool to assist
the researcher we just use the same tool
and find ways to scaffold it to use the
educational jargon or just wrap it in
contextual material that will help make
that something educationally useful
that's enough for now for me let's get
to the specifics of what's actually
happening in South Africa so I've done
it and just as other people here at
cetera other researchers investigators
have since antiretroviral therapy and
combination therapy came into play
roughly around 1996 a lot of us have
paid attention to the need for high
levels of adherence for people to have
good
clinical outcomes so a lot of this work
is done domestically several of us work
in South Africa in particular because
there's such a high burden of HIV in
that part of the world in sub-saharan
Africa and particularly in South Africa
so you can see the numbers of millions
of people infected and the numbers
continuing to rise of those who are
eligible for art art stands for
antiretroviral therapy but there's one
physician / 1300 patients compared to in
the u.s. roughly 1 / 3 90 so our
adherence and retention problems are
growing concern we've made great
advances in our treatment for HIV but we
don't have a cure it's lifelong therapy
and it's lifelong therapy of daily
medication dosing for most people used
to be three four or five times a day for
people for most people it's two times a
day or some can do 11 a day regimen but
you still have to have extremely high
levels of adherence so that you don't
develop a resistant virus and again have
good clinical outcomes so what's
happening in the South African context
is health clinics task shifting to meet
the debt demands and allocate resources
there aren't enough physicians and
nurses and very few mental health
providers such as social workers or
psychologists to be available in
clinical settings to do what we call it
here is consoling to talk to help
patients access care stay in care and to
understand and have like I levels of
medication adherence our goal is to have
people not miss a single dose of their
medication and all of us are human
beings and normal adherence is much less
than one hundred percent normal
adherence is between 50 and 75 percent
or eighty percent and that includes all
of us so we need to try and get people
above ninety percent and that's why
there's so much work in HIV about
adherence the broader context there also
is the widespread poverty and stigma and
then those people here are working on
stigma a lot of alcohol and mental
health problems again this is not unique
to this context we can say a lot about
New Haven and the
sitting in other places in the u.s.
there is limited knowledge among
communities and patient population about
the the concept of resistance and the
consequences of non-adherence the
consequences of missing a dose every now
and then or taking a break for a weekend
or a week there are a lot of
misconceptions about whether it's okay
or not okay to do that and as I
mentioned the lack of sufficient patient
provider communication just lack of time
for it and then there are cultural
issues around traditional medicine and
myths regarding Western medicine there's
a lot of traditional medicine
traditional healing and people have
notions that you should do one versus
the other or you can't integrate them or
I shouldn't take these pills that come
from the Western world when I can go to
a traditional healer that has other
kinds of methods so a lot of us do work
about integrating traditional healing
and Western medicine in this context
there's a strong reliance on lay
counsellors they are people who
typically come from the community of the
populations are the most affected by
hiv/aids they are often HIV positive
themselves so they're often peers but
they are lay in the sense that they are
not professionally trained counselors
they're not mental health care providers
they haven't gone through a lot of
professional training they get training
centrally from an institute called
addict which is part of their Department
of Health from there from the province
and they basically go through a couple
weeks of basic training on how the
council people how to counsel people
about adherence but that's pretty
minimal because it's it's it's not an
easy thing to counsel people on so what
happens is there's wide variability in
the support and supervision that happens
in the clinics when these minimally
trained counselors go out then into the
real world and they're assigned to
clinics and they're having to see
hundreds and hundreds of patients to
teach them about adherence and to keep
them on track and address problems in
people's lives so there's a lack of
standardized standardized curriculum or
the content or a number of sessions
bottom line is wide variability in the
adequacy of the counseling that's taking
place
and in South Africa also it was quickly
recognized that not unlike here but I'd
say even more powerfully there there's a
lot of stigma around HIV which some of
us might think is surprising in a
population where there are so many
people living with HIV in some
communities where we're talking about
forty to sixty percent HIV prevalence
you'd think stigma would be reduced but
it's actually unfortunately not true
there's a lot of stigma so it stays
hidden people are afraid to be tested
people are afraid to access care they
don't want anyone else to know that
they're on medicine so they learn pretty
quickly that when medicine became
available in South Africa that as they
started distributing it people who had
told nobody in their lives that they had
HIV and they were taking medicine were
had a higher percentage of defaulting or
not staying care and not taking their
medicine because anyone they want to
know so they'd hit it or they forget
about Italy they take it and they'd stop
taking it so they developed a policy
where people had to identify a treatment
buddy a support partner that they
disclose to and that they actually bring
to the clinic before they are given
their antiretroviral medication before
they started on treatment so that's a
policy that everyone has a quote unquote
treatment buddy there were concerns
about how effectively that was being
used and was the person really a buddy
or was it just someone that they tapped
in the waiting room or down the block
and said come be my buddy so I can get
my meds and I'll do the same for you and
a lot of that was going on and then they
weren't necessarily real support
partners in the person's life to help
them stay on treatment the old cliche it
takes a village you know we're working
with a lot of lot of collaborating
institutions you already heard about CCN
MTL in our center but also department
psychiatry university cape town and the
public health department there there's a
social intervention group is another
group at at Columbia University we work
with the city and provincial health
departments which i think is very
important and I know that Sarah actually
does a lot of work with with health
apartments as well and then we
collaborate a lot with a specific clinic
that we worked in so here's a picture of
the clinic it's actually a fairly nice
decent relatively modern building but
everything goes on in this building
pretty much you know doctors nurses
anything that happens the pharmacy
everything is containing this one
building but what I want to point out is
that this building and this clinic is
serving predominantly a local township
which you can see how close and proximal
the township is this is a very very
extensive township of this kind of
housing this is actually a little bit
more of an upscale Township and that it
has electricity you can see the wires
each household may or may not have
running water and actually some of the
households may or may not have
functioning electricity this is the
population that is predominantly being
served and this is just one snapshot of
the clinic waiting room I was looking at
this picture last night I'm you know you
see mostly women and children and it's
families it's not an HIV clinic the
general clinic but there's a lot of HIV
prevalence so a lot of people there for
HIV care but not everyone the men there
it serves a lot of men as well they tend
to kind of hang outside and not
necessarily sit in the waiting room so
you're seeing about us maybe a half to
two-thirds of the people that are there
to see someone within the next few hours
okay so a lot of men hanging outside as
well there's Ryan talk about the
collaborative process so this is this is
the happen to be the pharmacist in that
clinic a lot of page a lot of written
paper and pencil records but a desire to
move more towards computer-based and
digital medical records so that's why
she's working off a laptop trying to get
the paper and stuff into a digital
tracking of pharmacy and pharmacy result
these refills etc
so we're coming from a research we've
been funded by research from ni-mh we
got it r34 grant to address the need for
standardized adherence counseling and I
had I was the principal investigator of
a study called smart couples which was
we had done an efficacy trial on our own
randomized controlled trial of testing
an intervention that was the first
intervention that was dyadic based for
adherence most of the interventions and
prickly at the time were just
patient-centered just focused on the
patient we said I had been doing work
with Sarah discordant couples around
sexual risk behavior and family planning
and other things like that we said let's
address adherence in the context of a
couple and move this towards a more
dyadic support partner kind of thing so
we were actually had a successful trial
in doing an intervention with patients
who were having problems with adherence
and their HIV negative primary partner
wife husband we had same-sex couples
predominantly heterosexual couples in
this study so we thought that was a
model a theoretical model on the real
model for the buddy system because
that's a diet so we thought we could
take this notion the dyadic intervention
even though that was couple based into a
broader any support partner whether it's
a sister a friend a mother a neighbor
adult child or whatever that support
buddy is and this is where then our
collaboration began of thinking about
how computer technology can be useful in
conveying information particularly for
low literacy populations we also want
and we think that where we've developed
is engaging it is standardized because
the scaffold is in the program in the
computer and it's delivered by lay
counsellors a lot of this is we sort of
framed and approached this is how can we
enhance the capacity of what these Lake
Ounces are able to do which is a little
bit different from thinking what can we
build that we can just put patients in
front of
so just to say that this came from smart
couples what are you see in our logo
come on don't be shy hmm oh that's not
what I smile well right most people when
they think okay I see two people it's a
couple actually I see a rock I see a
smiling frog so anyway so as I said this
came off of an IM h ro 1 trial it was
the first efficacious dyadic adherence
intervention it actually just very
recently the CDC I know those of you
know about Debbie's an Debbie's but they
have effective behavioral interventions
prevention is a large portfolio of about
70 intervention primary prevention they
just came out with a recommendation of
878 I think efficacious adherence
interventions of which smart couples is
one of them and they've chosen five of
which ours is one for wide-scale
dissemination so that's just the status
of that study but I want to talk we were
going to talk now about our work since
then with the r34 to develop this
intervention assess the capacity of
counselors to use this laptop based
intervention but you'll hear about we
first had resistance about the notion of
using a laptop in such resource
constrained settings we want to assess
the acceptability of the intervention
among the issues and the providers the
feasibility of delivering the
intervention in a very very busy clinic
setting and of course then you do in
these are 34 just preliminary evidence
that there might be some efficacy that
you might be at least moving in the
direction of the outcomes you're
interested in as most of our research is
done it's based on a theoretical
framework in this case we use social
action theory because we think and I
think it encompasses the kind of
behaviors and addressing the issues that
are necessary when you talk about
adherence behaviors someone having the
information the knowledge information is
necessary but not sufficient there's
choose around self regulatory process
about moved and around motivation and
you can throw substance use in that into
the whole self regulatory process it
takes into account this larger social
context specifically stigma and
disclosure issues into personal
processes social support communication
and then the behavior itself the theory
talks about the need for self-efficacy
and skills to enact the behavior and to
maintain that behavior the content of
the intervention we we've built a lot of
things into it we recognize that mental
health problems are a barrier to optimal
adherence well we this intervention
specifically is not treating mental
health problems we wanted to incorporate
the awareness of it there actually is
available mental health services in the
settings we work in psychiatrists and
psychologists rotate through the
clinic's they can come and provide
psychiatric services and address and
treat depression and things like that
but what happens in these settings is
they go undetected and undiagnosed so
it's not even recognized that this
patient is having such a problem with
hearing is is severely depressed and no
one's even thinking about that are
realizing it so we want to develop a
screening tool we want to help people
choose a treatment buddy that wasn't
just the person they tapped in the
waiting room that it was a more
thoughtful process we want to impart a
lot of information about HIV how does
the virus work what is what is adherence
mean what does resistance mean was it
mean if you don't take your pill what
does it mean to take pills when I'm not
sick and I'm not even feeling sick and
especially if I take the pills and that
makes me feel sick so education around
the importance of adherence and what
it's doing and you inside your body then
of course solving problems that are
barriers to it here and so the adherence
berry berries are the many levels
structural societal stigma into personal
personal individual motivation there's a
lot of levels where things get in the
way of good adherence we want to
incorporate helping people with
disclosure and social support teach a
little bit about HIV prevention
transmission and what we generally call
prevention with positives and also
couched around reasons to stay healthy
to me this is a really important slide
that I just want to say to you on that
and I think a lot of the work that comes
out of a center like Sarah you know
knows this and does this kind of work
but it's really important to involve
stakeholders I think from the day one of
the deciding a study deciding what the
aims of a study are or hypotheses but
also to building an intervention I know
colleagues and not here at this Center
but people who might develop an
intervention full-scale and then go to a
community and say here we have this
intervention we want you to use it and
providers will look at it and go it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense or I
wouldn't you that's technique I wouldn't
you know we believe in working with with
the stakeholders from day one and that
includes providers counselors patient
advocates or peers from the community
the patient's themselves and support
partners we brought them into the
process of developing this intervention
as well as researchers technology
experts and the health department it was
important that we work with the buy-in
and collaboration of the health
department because how they going to
institute this how they going to scale
it up ultimately if it's shown to be
effective and it's an iterative feedback
and you can do that in person but you
can also use technology like skyping and
inside and things like that we had a lot
of back and forth which you'll hear a
little bit about so actually if you we
want to show you a few pieces of the
intervention do I need to stand next to
this one as well or yeah okay I'll do
this because we're going to try and show
you a few things in here yeah so I
mentioned the mental health screening so
the question we had was this
intervention can't treat depression or
anxiety disorder post-traumatic stress
but can we empower and enable lay
counsellors to screen for it now there
are standardized screening tools for
these kinds of disorders and so we took
a standardized screening tool that's
been shown to be a good screener and we
put it
to the computer we put into the computer
so that the council doesn't have to even
necessarily understand what all these
symptoms mean or you know how to score
it or you know when you use a screening
that's been shown to be valid and
reliable you want the person too who's
administering it to use the words
exactly as written so they get to use
this are we showing it or we're just
using the slides with these two but all
swap over oh then you'll swap over okay
so what happens in this and it's a live
thing you asked the question the
counselor has the question and then
ticks in the answers and what happens if
the answers get automatically scored
they don't have to sit there and score
they just stick them automatically
scored and then it automatically scores
in two categories of no distress mild
moderate severe and then we develop
scripts for if it's severe just to
remind them we're giving the language to
say you know I'd like to make a referral
if it's mild if it's mild they say
something like you know well I can see
you're having some trouble if you feel
like you want to talk about it you can
but you know maybe we'll check in next
time but if it's severe you want to try
and intervene and make the referral
right then and there so we'll be
studying how successful this is in
referrals happening and the mental
health care happening as a consequence
so just to describe the what it looks
like in the scaffolding of it and we're
actually modifying it right now from our
pilot study there's some amount of texts
that gives the counselor a scaffold for
what am i doing now in this session and
so you give a little bit the text of the
you know goals of this session are a
reminder and then they can go to the
session and go to specific activities so
I think we try and go to the support
tree so here they get there and so this
is we're going to show you in a minute
where we started but this is where we
ended up because of our collaborators
and they developed the image and
metaphor of a tree as a way of talking
about one social support and one of the
counselors there said I sit with my
patient my client and I say who's in
your support tree
and he said I actually draw pictures of
fruit and put names in the fruit so they
sit there and put names in like Ryan's
doing right now tell me who's close to
you who's involved in your life and you
know Peter and gabe and Ryan and Bob and
Claude I recognize these names including
Gabe and then what the next part is tell
me of these people who you've actually
disclosed to who knows you're living
with HIV so you tick on three of those
and the color of the fruit changes and
then my next question as the counselor
is let's talk about who can provide
support for you emotional support or
food if you are hungry or can help you
with transportation if you need it or a
babysit your kid and now we've narrowed
it down to two people that are probably
two potential candidates for real
support partners that really could be a
support buddy for you a treatment buddy
for you and can come and join us for the
remainder of the intervention so it's
using this as a way we think of
enhancing the capacity of the counselor
to go through a thoughtful process
that's somewhat engaging visually to
think about and then at any point we
have it set up so that the patient you
can print a print button and they can
take home a print of this of this slide
or any of the slides or any of the
activities you'll see so we have a a
pill activity
it's important that people know what
their medicine is and how often they're
supposed to take it and how many times a
day and which ones they take in the
morning and which ones they take at
night because people do get confused and
people patients and this happens here
and I see it in clinical settings i work
in patients think they're being in
hearing one of these i take one of these
and then when it's checked it's like
we'll know you're actually supposed to
taking two of these in the morning and
only you know three of these at night
that kind of thing so we put in pictures
of the pills to challenge when the pills
change but that's another issue and then
you tick off the ones that the years and
then you go to the next part and you can
start to move the pills back and forth
so you can do this with the patient
let's look what do you do which pills
are you taking in the morning which ones
at night depending on how you do this
the counselor you know should have some
basic knowledge of what the regimens are
and to be able to say well actually
that's not you know you should be taking
two of these or they could always check
with the pharmacist or the nurse so that
they get it correct but the timing is
also an issue ideally to be adherent and
have coverage therapeutic coverage you
want twice a day to be roughly 12 hours
apart we're pretty close to 12 hours
apart three hours a day you wanted eight
hours apart I've seen people who say I
had twice a day dosing I take these
pills in the morning when I get up and
they take the rest at lunch it's not the
best coverage because that's not 12
hours so you got you put in the times
and it's a way of having a conversation
about how your dosing and when your
dosing we can't show you everything we
can I show you a few things but I want
you to get a flavor of how this
intervention works the island activity
so this this was a metaphor that really
was developed locally it's hard to
describe viral load cd4 what are those
things what does it mean opportunistic
infections what are those health what
does inherent have to do with it all our
collaborators locally came up with this
we happen to be doing this in a fishing
village in a lot of South Africa is near
the coast so water was a metaphor island
was a metaphor where if you you play
with that's the viral
load if you can't read it so the viral
loads going up and you can talk about
whether how much virus is in your body
what happens is you see the force start
to go down see the four are those cells
that help your immune system when that
happens you have opportunities for
opposite that can affect optimistic
infections so this notion of going under
the water what else do you observe going
on with the changes
hey sometimes it's subtle although on
the screen that people can see it pretty
quickly when you're on the computer
persons getting skinny when he goes
underwater the notion of illness and HIV
illness in this context is identified as
weight loss that's how and when people
say I think I think he or she has the
aids and then they speak in that kind of
language it's if you're losing weight
that means you're sick if you're heavy
and gaining weight you're robust you're
healthy so with these movements the
person looks more and more gone they
came up with these kinds of notions and
concepts okay no I think the only other
thing will show you is the fact that we
have videos built in here so there are
other activities like this that are
interactive that you play with things
but what you also built in was and
actually this is a good video of the
show because this was actually developed
with Yale University collaborators we
did not we didn't shoot or develop this
video we access has used it and it's in
the public domain and we spoke with the
people who developed it was folks in
South Africa Jerry Friedman was one of
the people involved and it's called
snakes and soldiers video because it's a
metaphor I've got developed for teaching
about hiv/aids let's just show you like
to I'm in two minutes or minute of it
for my script a minute or so yeah your
body's immune system wama so John resume
is an army of soldier cells that God
your body for sicknesses in like HIV
but HIV is a particularly vance's
because it not only fights your body it
also finds cd4 soldier cells HIV is like
a poisonous snake sneaking up to the CD
for soldiers while they're sleeping and
killing these snakes are smooth and hide
so the soldiers cannot find them to
fight very quickly multiply until they
overwhelm the city for soldiers and the
body becomes very ill this is where ARVs
come in ARVs can prevent the
multiplication of the HIV virus it is as
if the body soldiers could find the HIV
sneakiness import drugs on the snake
eggs to keep the eggs for catching
however ARVs are kind of drug that only
works for a limited amount of time they
must be taken every day in the morning
and that you otherwise the HIV virus as
a chance to reduce it's a good problem
so this is this is a good you can
actually google it and find it and watch
the whole thing it's its people find it
to be very effective and it just teaches
about ARVs what happens the resistance
metaphor is that the eggshells get
hardened and then the air if you stop
taking the arabes when the soldiers fall
asleep then when you return to using
ARVs the shells are so hardened that the
arabes are not working on them and
that's resistance that's viral
resistance there's another part of the
video that actually has a whole scenario
of two characters called Joseph and hope
which are people who live in South
Africa they're young people and you see
how social support can help where hope
goes home with her medication and tells
her brother who she lives with about it
and you see her in the course of her
life running out of the house to go to
school and forgetting to take her
medicine with her and her brother
reminds her and she has social support
Joseph hides the medicines from his
mother who he lives with puts him under
the bed runs out doesn't take them
starts missing and you see them over
time and he gets very very sick he's
really in bed dying and she's healthy
and out going to parties and working so
if that also is in effect the video we
also developed a problem-solving video
that the counselors there wrote a script
for how to solve a problem with
with your buddy helping you and we then
filmed the video and that's part of the
problem solving so we don't have time to
show you more right so we're back in
actually when trying to talk few minutes
about the design process and how we got
to that support tree for instance so
looking at this stuff just on the face
of it it kind of looks like okay yeah
will you pick very relevant things that
look like they've matched very nicely
with the setting but well we didn't know
any of these things up front I think
it's useful to actually look at kind of
where we started and see how the clinic
taught us what to do because we were way
off and I just think it's illuminating
one thing we did as a team of us came to
the clinic with some initial ideas and
really SAT with the nurses that's one
way counselor there and really just
tried to understand what they're doing
and what materials they already had what
kinds of narratives are metaphors they
tried to use for different steps in the
process and then we showed them some of
our initial designs that we had actually
put into the grant proposal so what I'm
going to show you now is what we had
drawn up that preceded the tree so you
remember the trees for picking the the
treatment buddy you're going to laugh
looks very kind of high-tech right looks
very kind of you know like something you
would see on an iPad you know are you
dragging things around and clicking
things right and this didn't resonate
with them at all at all no surprise
right but we were able to explain it
enough to then draw out how they do it
and then we did what they do as opposed
to what we had in mind and that carried
through in some of the future designs as
well this is just another screen of our
very poor first attempt the whole idea
with the thinning out of the of the
person in the island is similar we saw
these posters in the clinic that were
depicting what people look like and we
try to accommodate that in the drawing
that we did with the island I mean some
of our initial Island things were really
very ridiculous as well and I thought
they'd be kind of fun to check out
here's a first first couple attempts we
had a student from South Africa who was
on the team who had talked about being
in the market with scales and that maybe
there was a way to teach this sense of
like well when the viral load goes up
the CD pores go down but it's not that
simple and in fact can be
counterintuitive and it actually helping
someone understand this and again we
kind of we're still going toward this
kind of very computer looking kind of
thing as opposed to something more human
looking on and we really were taught by
the clinic staff themselves well don't
put up kind of I don't know a little
avatar looking kind of thing in there
put a person and actually draw it and
make it look like a person would look
and that will make a difference in how
well the counselor can communicate some
of these ideas to the patients that
they're working with and really that's
really the I want to say that again just
maybe another way that you really think
about what we're doing is trying to
extend the capabilities of what the
counselor can do more than anything else
and so all the design work the client of
the design in a way is the counselor in
order to make them more effective with
the people that they're trying to work
with
I don't know if we need to do any more
than that Bob to kind of make it right
yeah so that back to you right good so
yeah and so let me just show you these
just screenshots so problem solving we
see is as one essential in my smart
couple study and a lot of other
interventions there's a lot of focus on
problem solving what's the problem let's
look at the possible brainstorm some
solutions let's think about which one we
can try which one we can try and so we
also I with we were informed what are
the common barriers there so we have
about 14 barriers we have an image a
picture for the barriers like drinking
or being too long at the clinic or the
medication makes me feel sick as
barriers to taking my pills and then we
developed this video where it's modeling
to people these are two friends
addressing a problem and again they
wrote the script of the video in South
African actors would actually they were
Columbia students who were South African
who we shot the video with so it's
applied to person's personal barriers
and yeah i'm not going to i'm not going
to pause on these things but here's just
one example you know of what's the
problem well when I drinking my friends
I don't take my tablets that's another
word for pills I don't take my pills
this actually came out of the
intervention so what's my goal to drink
less on the weekends how can I possibly
do that well I can be abstinent I cannot
drink at all i can try to take my
tablets with me when I go out and be
better at that I can spend less time
with my drinking friends in this example
that was what they focused on and the
buddy actually helped the person stop
hanging out with those drinking friends
on the weekend and she found a way to
you know to help let's do something else
on the weekend spend time with this
weekend with a friend who doesn't drink
and you know that's just an example but
this is a live example that came out of
our pilot study ok and that's Joseph
let's hope talking to her brother in the
video I mentioned the other thing that
we were working with South African
fellows who were at our center and they
were looking at this in the early stages
they said what about people's motivation
why are they staying healthy and they
said what about using that whole
mountain thing to think about my
proximal and my more distant goals so
the proximal going back to work persons
sick I want to be healthy to go back to
work I want to get healthy so I can take
care of my mother I want to be there for
my son's wedding is the rest of that
third goal the top one has become a
grandfather so this again was live and
came out of what someone came up with as
they're so the motivating goals like why
don't why is it important to stay
healthy so I'm going to very quick hi
Jerry I just mentioned your name a
little earlier we let me tell you very
quickly because I we want to leave a
little bit of time for some discussion
so we did complete the r34 study so we
kind of went quickly through this whole
development process developing this
intervention and then we tried it with
65 patients who refer for having poor
adherence we we mimic that a trial of
randomizing them interestingly most of
the buddies selected through the support
tree process were not the buddies they
had selected when they first got their
meds probably not a surprise though
right when you think about how they
typically have done it high and high
retention rate of the within the
intervention two-thirds were women and
you saw that picture of the clinic
mostly women not highly educated mostly
not employed and this majority will cosa
speaking in this context so remember the
picture of the clinic this is directly
across from the clinic this is called a
Wendy house you go in and there's a
small little waiting room in this to
counseling rooms that's where a lot of
the counseling took place so this is
just one of our facilitators I just want
to show you it's as Ryan said this is we
we built this as a way for the counselor
to have something interactive to work
with their patient and buddy this is not
self-directed you don't turn this over
necessarily to the patient stay here you
know go sit with this for a half hour
and I'll come back this is an
interactive process interactive so they
look at the screens
together they play with the viral load
and cd4 and see the person go up and
down and get skinny and heavy so that's
how it's and they do it in whatever
space they can do it in and this is also
why it's not internet-based why it's all
contained the one in the middle the one
thing in front of the computer for the
most part the counselor manipulated the
computer patients could and you know but
they often wouldn't they would just kind
of look at it together you know then
when they show the video they just sit
there and look at it together so despite
the small sample size we have promising
results we saw a more promising positive
change in days between pharmacy refills
self-reported the medication adherence
psychiatric distress social support for
adherence HIV treatment knowledge so
these are part of the theoretical
components of our model for what we were
intervening on to bring them to improve
adherence I'm going to go through these
very quickly these are small samples
these are just like that is it moving in
the direction we want it to move in and
so we did see more less delay in
returning to the clinic to pick up their
meds in the intervention arm compared to
the control arm we saw and this is just
self-reported adherence which a lot of
people don't think is a very strong
measure of adherence but we see greater
improvement in self-reported adherence
for our intervention and control arm
this is just no way of asking a
self-reported adherence question
thinking about the last four weeks
social support seem to improve more
dramatically in the intervention on than
the control arm since its distress is
something we assess and I remember this
intervention is not treating distress we
are screening for it and referring we
did see improvements in our distress
measure which is that standardized
measure in the treatment arm and finally
we see a crossover an increase in
treatment knowledge in the intervention
group but again these are you know these
are not statistically significant these
are just this remember this is the r34
grant it was really more about
developing and the feasibility outcome
so our outcomes in terms of feedback is
our target population found that
visually engaging they like the
interactive activities that we people
love the videos they really like the
videos and one of the videos Jerry I
mentioned that we incorporate into this
is one that you involved in with the
snakes and soldiers video that was done
in Johannesburg and so we developed a
video but we also were able to use a
video that already existed that people
found had a powerful metaphor they said
they learn things they had not
understood like the importance of
adherence how the error v's work and
what resistance is and I love this quote
I learned things about HIV and how the
medications work in masiva Kenny that I
never got from my counselors before
remember these are people who had
initial counseling but now they've got
this counseling and they say you know I
learned things here that I really never
understood or heard before and a lot of
support was generated for problem
solving the partners themselves often
living with HIV themselves found
benefits in their own health they liked
helping their friend learn from problem
solving and they like the videos the
counselors remember we frame this is we
developed this to enhance their capacity
they were really our main target
audience in developing this tool they
felt it was it was a support tool for
them giving them a road map or a
scaffold for doing their work guided me
through the sessions helped me to pay
attention to to my patient and Buddy and
they felt it actually empower them or
enabled them to do that screening that
mental health screening and alcohol use
screening to make referrals to the
psychologist or whoever else was
available in this in the setting and the
providers what they really liked was the
standardized tool nature of this they
saw positive changes in the few patients
have been through the intervention
remember we targeted people having
problems with adherence they but they
said you know what we want this to be
used for all our patients when they
start into retroviral therapy we don't
want to wait so they have problems we
then to understand these things and the
other really cool thing was that the
head nurse there who at first was a
little bit resistant and you know it's
like going to some of these settings
like oh god research what do you want to
do here you know
but became a real collaborator they
named the intervention they developed
metaphors they feel real ownership she
said I want all my providers and my
nurses and my pharmacist to be trained
on this because I want us all to be used
in the same language I want us all to
refer to that Island when our patient
comes in they want the pharmacist to do
that they want the nurse to do that so
they've really own it and they've
adopted it which is a very nice thing to
see they like the standardized
counseling message they also like the
fact that this tool if a person goes in
it basically takes 20 to 40 minutes to
go through a session and that's what
they expect out of their councils when
someone's having a problem they refer
them to the council they say you know I
want you to see this patient and you
know for at least 20 minutes or
something very often they would witness
the person going into the Wendy house
with the counselor and coming out in
five minutes well what happened in that
counseling session nobody knows they
feel like if this is going to guide them
through and put them through a process
and standardize our delivery of our
messages great that's what we want so we
think to sum this up that it's
standardizes delivery of information
provides a guided framework or a
scaffold empowers counselors visually
engaging very useful for low literacy
its interactive you can personalize
things all this information gets
recorded about that patient like their
goals and their problems and their
problem-solving that you can revisit the
next time they come in because it's all
there so if facilitates data collection
in that regard we found it to be highly
acceptable and having promise of
adherence behavior change so you know
thus and in the research world you want
to go from an r34 to an ro1 so we as
soon as we had these these kinds of
outcomes we applied for an ro1 then we
were just funded in August to UM to do a
randomized control trial of this
intimate and it was fun to Don its first
submission and very quickly because i
want to give Ryan a few minutes um I
don't have to belabor this you know it's
an RCT we're going to develop but we're
primary outcomes we're looking at our
remember we're starting with people who
are initiating
therapy so we want viral load to be an
outcome primary outcome one-year
follow-up and we also want what we think
of as a more objective measure of
adherence and for those of you who may
or may not know we're going to be using
a wild spiel device which we did pilot
test in the setting this is you can see
what it looks like you can put pills in
there every time that's opened a
cellular signal ascent so you can do
real-time monitoring of adherence and it
also records opening and closing you
don't know if the person is putting the
pillow on their mouth like with MEMS
caps but people have been having success
and colleague of ours david bangs burger
and other people have been using this
widely almost wrapped up and then we
have a lot of secondary aims in this
study so i'm just going to leave that
there well now let me show you this so
this is this is basically the study but
I actually want where's that just to
repeat their allah the collaborators
involved and you see the names of all
the people involved i want to bring we
want to bring it back to the larger
context of where we started with what
Ryan talked about and we both talked
about about how do we think of
technology and and where and how is it
best applied and that's what actually
Ryan's going to talk about for our last
light alright and I'll try to be quick
because I know we're approaching the end
of the ton so bob is one of maybe about
six or seven projects like this that our
centers been in golf with over the last
three or four years and we're noticing a
few things and we thought it would be
important to point these out that
something broader than just one
particular study that Bob's working on
and that is that you know funding
agencies like the NIH are starting to
put out announcements asking researchers
to think through you know how to make
use of various new media tools
technology you know one example i pulled
out is you know from the
from nursing institute within nih has to
do with just how do you effectively use
mobile health tools or m health is sort
of the catchphrase that's out there but
there are dozens of these coming out
everywhere and it's important to think
through well what do you how do you
approach that as a as a researcher in
this area and we have a technique and a
point of view that we've been developing
for a few years now that we think works
and I've just tried to summarize that in
these three bullets here below with you
know thinking carefully about well what
is the the role of the tech in the
intervention and as we've said it 20
different ways today we're talking about
enhancing person-to-person communication
in this instance not replacing or trying
to just find the latest gadget out there
and leverage it you know for some
outcome that we're not so sure about but
instead of really carefully with the
very close participatory design model ID
a problem that we think technology can
add value to and then and then really
hone in on that really carefully going
bigger than that I hope that and I think
I summarize this a bit in the beginning
as well that the things that we're
learning and putting into these tools
can find their way into other parts of
university life whether that's taking
some of the videos that are developed
and putting them into a classroom just
to learn some of the basics in the same
way that the patients have to learn the
basics or critically analyzing like how
well we've culturally adapted this
particular intervention to this setting
and having public health students really
examine that carefully or maybe think
about a third setting or a fourth
setting and there are ways that we can
not have to rebuild the tools and still
get a you know big big value add in
terms of an authentic experience for
students in classroom settings and to me
the way to make this really happy that
is and the reason I'm so proud of what
we've done so far and so looking forward
to seeing what we can do in the next
study is really this cvpr process that
took place in this particular project
I've never seen it happen as well as it
did here it's a credit to Bob in the
collaborators in cape town and everyone
else that we that we work with that we
were able to get the clinic so wrapped
into helping us make what we've made
which i think i said to some of the
fellows earlier when we were here the
morning that building the tech product
or buying tech product or however you
choose to incorporate into some work
that you're doing is only one of about
eight things that have to go right for
one of these studies to really work
everything from that well how do we
train the counselors appropriately how
do we create a kind of welcoming
environment that the the tool will be
accepted in this setting and I mean one
just one little detail we never
mentioned it's in English well you
wouldn't think that we wanted to do it
in English but the clinic insisted
please do it in English the pharmacy
bottles are in English but the way the
medical terminology is communicated is
in English don't change it and you know
the [ __ ] the counselors can do the
translation as needed a lot of issues
like that and we should I just suggest
that you know anybody thinking about
ways of using media in in these kinds of
these kinds of tools should try as best
they can to really get the people that
you're targeting involved in the process
because it will just pave the way for a
better implementation and a better
chance for success going forward